now let's talk about the suite of
technologies that make civilization 3.0
possible
the first is what i call mobile real
estate
we're also advancing in the area of what
google's astro teller calls mobile
infrastructure
even movable cities
first they're settled communities with a
very light footprint we're investing in
the technologies to nourish ourselves
without destabilizing the environment
the dutch for example have a national
circular strategy and towns that collect
rain water and do wastewater treatment
and recycling they have solar power and
hydro and aquaponic agriculture
okay
small and mobile villages that sounds
good for millions of people
what about for hundreds of millions of
people
what about places like cairo
cairo faces insufficient nile river
water while alexandria faces a rising
mediterranean sea
the people of alexandria and cairo need
desalination and they need more
efficient crop irrigation
but beware of spending billions of
dollars
on irrigation to sustain agriculture in
places where the water supply is at risk
and the delicate range of air
temperature that's right for growing
food ultimately many people in egypt
will have to relocate
skyscrapers could well become the
stranded assets and detritus of our
present civilization
like the pyramids of ancient egypt
or they may become air-conditioned
shelters part of an archipelago of
mixed-use facilities all within a domed
city
which is exactly what's being planned
for parts of dubai
if we stay where we are
we are at best a survival society
instead we should move and we should
build a new